olá meu nome é nicole e hoje vou falar
sobre assunto muito importante que a
poluição
primeiramente o que é a poluição
eu acho que todos vocês já sabem a
poluição é mais ou menos o que destrói
as nossas cidades ea nossa natureza
existem os poluentes sólidos que são os
intuitos as obras e as fezes
os poluentes líquidos que são as águas
sujas e os poluentes gasosas que a gente
já está bem acostumado aqui na cidade
que isso é uma fumaça que sai dos carros
ea fumaça que sai das indústrias a
poluição também causa vários problemas
em alguns países a poluição é tanta que
as pessoas precisam usar máscaras para
conseguir respirar direito
a sujeira também também causa vários
problemas nas nossas cidades que é que
também alguns países inclusive aqui no
brasil
a sujeira é tanta que a cidade ficar com
o mau cheiro é cheia de lixo e
totalmente poluída e à degradação das
cidades e da natureza que também
inclusive aqui no brasil
a sujeira é tanta que as cidades ea
natureza ficam totalmente degradadas
como nós podemos solucionar esse
problema tão grave
bom eu vou falar pra vocês a
conscientização das pessoas é muito
importante as pessoas precisam ter
consciência para conseguir resolver esse
problema tão grave
a reciclagem também é muito importante
pois os cacos de vidro podem se tornar
num vidro bem mais forte ea utilização
como esses enfeites de maçã feita de
garrafa pet é um ótimo exemplo ea
mudança em poluição o que ganhamos com
isso
bom nós ganhamos saúde para todos
a saúde é muito importante para nossa
convivência
as cidades mais limpas e verdes como
inclusive aqui no brasil
a cidade de maringá considerada uma das
mais verdes ea natureza preservada como
por exemplo nós fomos nesse lugar que é
a cachoeira do caracol que nós vimos
e essa área totalmente preservada
totalmente verde e eu fiquei muito feliz
de ver essa cá adversária preservada
porque a gente já está tão acostumado
com a poluição aqui no brasil que eu até
fiquei emocionada de ver essa cachoeira
preservada ea conclusão
bom nós devemos respeitar a natureza e
usar o exemplo dos três erres reduzir
reutilizar e reciclar
bom vocês já reciclaram nas suas casas
você já utilizaram alguma coisa
bom é melhor vocês fazer isso porque nós
te devemos ajudar a natureza
muito obrigada e até a próxima